ciao ragazzi bentornati non ho puntata
di vita ha buttata il tema della puntata
di oggi ha esperienze lavorative
dall'origine dell'uomo sulla terra
genesi 3 16 24 quando dio
rivolgendosi alla donna disse io
moltiplicherò grandemente le pene i
dolori della tua gravidanza con dolore
partorirà i figli i tuoi desideri si
volgeranno verso tuo marito e dei
regnerà su di te e ad adamo disse bla
bla bla insulti improperi anche a lui
mangerai il pane con il sudore del tuo
volto finché tu ritorni nella terra da
cui fosti tratto perché sei polvere è in
polvere ritornerai
in questo dolcissimo augurio di dio ea
millenni di distanza di uomini
continuano spezzarsi la schiena per un
pacco di riso e le donne continuano a
partorire con dolore ma lavorano pure
per mezzo acqua di riso la definizione
di lavoro è da ricondursi al latino
labor fatica ed è proprio con fatica che
i laureandi di tutto il mondo lanciano
il tocco in aria per prendere al volo il
cappello di mcdonald vero benefattore
che da sempre ha saputo dare spazio alle
nuove leve nelle sue cucine una dei
massimi esperti del settore che da
sempre condotto quella che si può
definire una vita semplice all'insegna
della morigeratezza alla domanda cosa ne
pensi del lavoro risponde e che cazzo è
paris hilton il lavoro dai tempi del
dolcissimo augurio di cui sopra è stato
harari campi spaccare legna coltivare
cotone ci sono affiancate a queste
figure anche e medici ingegneri e
avvocati l'era del digitale ha creato
figure di spicco ribattezzando i
muratori di fette biscottate lanciatori
di coriandoli sollevatori di forchette
smacchiatori di leopardi in influencer a
suon di codici sconto e te dimagranti
questi cattedratici hanno esteso il loro
impero fino a realizzare il motto di
ogni politico perché lavorare quando
possiamo non lavorare ed è per questo
che ho deciso di invitare all'interno
degli studios di casa mia a un ospite
tra i più importanti nella gestione dei
cattedratici di cui sopra l'avete già
vista l'avete richiesta l'avete amata
noi l'abbiamo assunto all'interno della
uim bush lei e graziana graziana
bentornata all'interno di questo canale
benvenuto all'interno della willwoosh
quindi posso continuare a chiamarti
william potrebbe chiamarsi camp nou può
iniziare a chiamarmi capo supremo lei
graziana ragazzi la conoscete la mia
cara amica ma in realtà è anche un
bomba nel fare il lavoro che fa che ora
non mi sto a spiegare prima di partire
però graziana io vi chiedo di iscrivervi
a questo canale metterci un bel pollice
in su per la nostra nuova dipendente e
soprattutto di farci sapere quali sono
state le vostre esperienze e lavorative
più imbarazzanti assurde se sentite
legati di sottofondo e perché abbiamo
rinchiusi nel bagno perché stanno
facendo un delirio partiamo posso fare
un disclaimer prima di iniziare così
tanto lo tagliamo il presidente i video
grazie mille grazie per il tuo
contributo che non avete niente tagliato
partiamo quindi ascoltare i messaggi
pratica lavorava come bagnino in una
piscina lontananza vedo un signore fermo
che galleggiava tipo stile morto che ho
detto mi piacciono sia andato subito
verso il ring st correa tantissimo
scivolo mi spacco tutto un certo punto
cerco di entrare in acqua per venderlo e
questo paesi alzani guardia mi fa che
c'è io tutto con un braccio distrutti
faceva tutto a posto tutto posso solo
facendo pinera la figura di merda
importante a sorrento lato 20 ma perché
fate la pancia sotto ospite lavorando in
fiera avevo progettare uno stand per
questa società che si occupava di
elaborazione dati praticamente volevano
un banner con la scritta gesto non l'hai
sio e d'età questa scritta doveva andare
su questo banner che era dell o di fatto
che non so cosa sia andato storto è
uscito questo banner gigante con appunto
la scritta certan al ancora un lavoro
non sa cosa tu stia facendo la sta
facendo nel modo giusto complimenti si è
mantenuto il lavoro meglio ancora grande
satana
date le edizioni di matematica ad un
ragazzino di persone i diari sono
accorta che ogni tanto per il river
telefono e cantava foto alle visite tra
l'altro e l'avevo di studi anche
affollatissimi a 13 anni credo una t
shirt è accollata montone una
passamontagna ma non faccia differenza è
una cosa che puoi dire in generale sul
lavoro senza specificare allora non c'è
stato un periodo in cui stiamo cercando
gli stagisti ne avevamo la porta
d'ingresso che era totalmente
trasparente suo ragazzo è arrivato ha
sbattuto la faccia direttamente nella
porta tutto insanguinato e ha fatto il
colloquio con il mio ex capo con il naso
particolari sangue senza interrompersi
un secondo è notato dice no non è stato
preso un altro dedicare fama di mare è
uno che non vede la porta del partito io
ricordo invece una volta stavo lavorando
in un film questa è una cosa che in
realtà nessuno conosce quando inizia a
lavorare quando ti microfono e se tu vai
in bagno quel microfono rimane acceso a
meno che non venga abbassato dall'audio
o a meno che tu non lo spenga questo
microfono io non l'ho spento non lo
abbassato mamma ho fatto la traviata col
culo nel frattempo sono affatto guarda
ho capito che il bisogno di privacy ho
abbassato la mia collega uscita portava
via della spazzatura e c'era un
all'angolo che stava pisciando è andata
lì per dirgli di andarsene non pisciava
sopra i tendoni è questo qua è girato
gli ha pisciato addosso perché stiamo
sento sia acqua franati so che schifo di
gianmarco per colpa mia
cosa è successo gianmarco stimolando
miopie e ha fatto pipì sul mio gatto
si è girato e ha addosso militare tg ma
continui a direzione che praticamente
lavoravo in una concessionaria di
automobili quindi spiegato cliente tutti
i funzionamenti ma di famiglie durante
la spiegazione vado a connettere
bluetooth plate nonché mentre mostrava
punto le funzioni su car play venuto
fuori un messaggio da topolino al
momento di silenzio la moglie che era
seduta dietro stava guardando la
spiegazione per esordire con intanto
abbiamo avanti con la spiegazione poi a
casa mi spiegherei e topolino
non ci credo questa epica la figlia non
avrà un anno in area ma non è la
topolina tra moltissimi gli ha detto ti
aspetto a disneyland paris certo inter
abbiamo questo momento di ascolto dei
messaggi per passare a un giochetto ci
siamo sempre detti abbiamo degli ospiti
ma non abbiamo modo di conoscerli meglio
quindi fargli delle domande che ci
permettono un pochino di inquadrarli di
più anzi sono delle domande che noi
gireremmo anche a voi ragazzi quindi
commentate c'é qua sotto facendoci
sapere si sa qual è la vostra risposta
ma soprattutto le motivazioni ma non
abbiamo ancora idea di come chiamare
questo segmento stiamo cercando un nome
il segmento perché un segmento che tu
menti all'interno del ok quindi
benvenuti a il segmento in questo
momento del segmento ti farò delle
domande sempre legato ovviamente al tema
della puntata di oggi il lavoro ok
preferiresti andare a letto con tutti i
tuoi colleghi ogni volta che percepisce
lo stipendio o con ogni cliente ogni
volta che chiude un contratto con i
clienti ogni volta che chiudo mai ha
guardato le teneva a cercare il cliente
preferiresti essere assunta per cambiare
assorbenti a mani nude a tutte le
professoresse dell'università di roma la
sapienza può essere assunta come
raccoglitrice di seme all'interno
a casa riposo per anziani ma dove puoi
usare dei guanti domande e per capire il
tipo di lavoratrice che sei veramente a
mani nude mani non preferiresti
presentarti a un colloquio coperta solo
di miele pop corn o vestita in modo
rispettabile ma con una piriti era
addosso 25 minuti e mette un sonoro
boato accompagnato da un gas mefitico
che provoca con attimi due interlocutori
di rado vestita con la visiera altra
cosa preferiresti titillare lo scroto
del cane del tuo capo con il mignolo
ogni volta che entri al lavoro per
ottenere un giorno di ferie in più al
mese oppure ragazzi allattare il tuo
capo ad ogni pausa pranzo con delle
finte mammelle al fine di ottenere un
cospicuo bonus fine anno così ma
preferisco sempre ultima domanda sta
cavando benissimo preferireste essere
assunta e questo anche per voi sempre
come l'attrazione principale di un parco
acquatico dove list itala foca devi
imparare a bilanciare una palla
gonfiabile sul naso mentre metti versi
gutturali e ripete ogni minuto il tuo
nome cognome indirizzo di casa oppure
c'è una seconda opzione essere assunta
dalle frecce tricolore come donna
gabbiano una magica figura che viene
espulsa nell'atmosfera da un getto è
cosparsa di penne e con una busta della
spazzatura in bocca da saccheggiare
prima di poter aprire il paracadute e
atterrare al centro di un'arena dove ti
esibisci in un rituale di accoppiamento
con un tizio vestito da scatto non farò
mai la foca rituale di accoppiamento
dove essere lanciato in atmosfera con un
gabbiano viene venduta bene grazie ai
detto la tua ragazzi fateci sapere la
vostra cui finisce il segmento
riprendiamo completa buttata perché non
fa lavoravo alla reception di un albergo
e vengo chiamata data si capivano cosa
la cliente avesse perso vado a vedere
cosa fosse successo e alla fine della
fiera siamo stati a cercare in mezzo la
biancheria sporca di tutte le
i vibratori c'è la signora aveva
lasciato sul letto per accogliere sono
andata a fare una prova è commessa in
una frutteria tiene in pausa pranzo la
responsabile si chiacchierava così è un
attimo di silenzio lei con lo scià lance
che era seduto a terra si piega da una
parte e molla una puzzetta rumorosa per
fortuna non puzzolente
anche perché c'erano i clienti ma
rumorosa io ho fatto finta di niente
perché principessa aspira casa meglio le
puzze degli rotti e l'ho spinta a
digiuno controlli così come per
controllare quello di non mi fai un lei
controllato ti ho visto farlo grazie ad
essere sempre il tempo per definizione
all'interno della uil salma dei morti
viventi
siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata ragazzi si è piaciuta
condividerà con i vostri amici ma
soprattutto fateci sapere quali sono
state le vostre esperienze lavorative
sono le risposte ai giochi del segmento
per segmento ad ora io ringrazio
graziano quell'esatto bravissimo solito
capo grazie anche a voi per aver visto
questo video fino a qui mi raccomando
scrivete ci lasciate c'è un bel pollice
in su noi ci vediamo ti do mi attivate
la campanella ante grande emotivamente
che ci vediamo domenica con un episodio
decisivo avvisò derivi da buttare 221
tutto il quartiere [ __ ] guardano
ciao ragazzi
pugliano e poco una merda
ma sembra un disclaimer prima di
iniziare così tanto lo tagliamo il
presidente i video lo cita symantec e di
come ti ho detto che il mio fratello
cacciare fornire mangiarsela ci teneva a
far sapere a tutti che non era lui che
si rimangiava bensì i suoni co termine
dell'epoca
devo fare un disclaimer tanto lo
tagliamo marittima